tonight is the highly anticipated debut
of Michael Weatherly's new series bull
now the show shoots in New York but
Michael is here in California for the
Emmys I wanted him to feel at home so we
walked over to a spot here on the studio
lot called New York Street for a quick
chat but nothing is quick and easy when
it comes to Michael we're really in New
York we really are in New York right now
Kevin Kevin Frazier everybody that was
my doctor feeling fresh out of this jury
pool you're gonna get three not guilty
votes doctor bull doesn't sound anything
like dr. Phil but the new series is
based on dr. Phil's early days as a
trial consultant you see that he's smart
he's a smoker some of my favorite
moments take place in airports when I
when I hear people say dr. Bowe looking
forward to boat and every once in a
while somebody tries to slap my head and
I go up this bull doesn't get heads left
I get to play something different than I
did for 13 years but I'm still having a
ball and having a lot of fun and there's
a sense of humor
he said farewell to agent DiNozzo but
ball premieres tonight right after NCIS
launches its 14th season when Michael
found out about his primo Tuesday night
timeslot he reacted in the most
Weatherly way possible I jumped up and
down like a kangaroo who had just had
three cups of coffee I I think I just
kept hopping around and my wife was like
what's going on I'm like I can't tell
you yet I can't tell you yet because I
think all right here's the lead-in and
then I had to explain to my wife about
TV programming and then it got boring
but Michael better listen to his wife
blue Jana
he's just playing a psychologist while
she is a real doctor specializing in
internal medicine what I'm thinking is
if the acting thing goes sideways we're
just gonna set up a little private
practice somewhere and I'm gonna be in
charge of the like making it how much it
costs for the books and everything yeah
you'll go ten minutes with with with my
wife and it shows you you know you can
use talking about medical you thought
about medicine yeah right and I think I
could I think I could we could really
charge whatever we wanted oh hey look
Tom hey Tom how's the forklift business
Michael you gotta love him that is
Michael by the way Michael married
really really well he and boy Anna will
celebrate their seventh wedding
anniversary this month congratulations
guy and how about this during our
interview NCIS died family went out
there she FaceTime Michael just to say
hello he's very connected to spam
sucking at NCIS and bull what a great
one-two punch right